make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys are the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're getting into thou'rt well
it's technically not called for reborn
but it might as well be um it's
basically odin son going back to being
in the role of Thor
which I mean it's cool but I'd like Jane
Foster is Thor I mean I miss Jane Foster
restore she was awesome I mean I don't
know if we'll ever get a character or
get her going back to being Thor again
but she was awesome as Thor and I I
thought it was great storytelling but
this is Odin son going back to being the
being that character himself now what's
happened here the way this picks up is
is this is out in Thailand this is
actually kind of interesting because
technically speaking this should be in
Korea and I'll explain why here in a
second but this starts off in Thailand
and it actually starts off with Thor
having raided the temple of sit Iraq to
steal something called the warlocks I
now the warlocks I is a very very old
artifact this goes all the way back to
Thor 131 and that well technically
speaking it's yeah I guess it's man it's
weird journey in a mystery and Thor
anyway goes back to Thor's the 131 by
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby the warlocks I
was an artifact that if a person used it
they could basically dominate the minds
of others now morville has a lot of
artifacts like that right like like
different things like that Doctor
Strange can do that telepaths can do
that that's one of the things I want you
guys to keep in mind for future
reference when it comes to the Infinity
stones they are unique in their own
right in the sense of like there are
only one set of Infinity stones but
there's a lot of other objects out there
they can do something akin to it or are
sometimes equally dangerous like the
casket of ancient winters the Crimson
bands and the crimson gem of cyttorak
depending on how you use them they get
actually pretty damn dangerous but
Thor's raided the temple for the purpose
of capturing the eye and the reason why
is because following the destruction of
as Gardea basically the rebuild Asghar
that iron man had made following the
events of siege when man God had stormed
the the gates really of s giardia and
sort of you know tearing everything up
and basically destroyed the entire area
the weapons of Odin hid essentially was
like flung across the cosmos and travel
across the you know to different realms
that are not really grounds where
different places across really the main
Marvel Universe proper now there is an
indication here it has trouble to cross
the realms but Thor can't see into those
and we'll find out why here in a second
but the Warlocks eye is one of these
objects now the warlocks I remember
correctly was taken it was it was
discovered and then used against Odin
unsuccessfully and then Odin took it and
kept it inside the incumbent on Asgard
that's the way things work back then
it's one of the reasons why if you go
watch like the first Thor movie or Thor
2 you'll see that Odin
like all these weapons gathered around
his room those are weapons that he
gained over the years by defeating
various foes it's not things that just
always existed in inside of inside of
Asgard but with regards to the arrival
or I guess regards to the the temple
itself and why it should be in Korea the
reason for this is is twofold
the first is that because of the fact
that Thor had raided the temple he
cannibals the the servants of CID Iraq
in turn callin their champion who's a
newly reformed juggernaut the other
reason for this is because during the
original act essence which is to say the
various demons of other dimensions
gathering together to see who was the
strongest the crimson gem as it was
created by CID Iraq and left on earth
for some future person to find and
become the juggernaut that happened in
Korea it didn't happen in Thailand so
it's kind of an interesting thing now we
could largely assumed that like
different temples were made over the
years and we can sort of jump to that
assumption but the way it was originally
done the way it was covered in eighth
day juggernaut there was only ever just
one temple of CID Iraq there weren't
multiple temples but when you have
juggernaut showing up here we end up
finding out that when Kane Marco went
back to being the servant of CID Iraq
that he's more powerful now that he's
ever been before now a lot of that was
because when Cain Marko originally
gained the game the the crimson gem that
it was just a fraction of Citrix powers
and those powers that the potency would
wax and wane over the years of course
the most of the most notable example the
strongest juggernauts ever been was try
on juggernaut but aside from that this
is basically him more in tune with sin
Iraq being granted more power due to the
fact that presumably Sid Iraq realized
juggernaut could leave at any point in
time
instantly didn't want him to and so you
end up having Thor who's basically given
a hammer by by by one of the dwarves and
then shows up and then goes to smash it
on juggernaut and it doesn't work the
hammer goes to pieces remember Mjolnir
is was thrown into the Sun by Jane
Foster so as far as Jason Aaron's
telling us it's basically lost now it
won't be Thor will discovered eventually
I mean it's the nature of comics
everything that changes goes back to
being the same again but this hammer
doesn't work it just kind of fractures
on on juggernaut and so in turn where
juggernaut starts to like Pelt Thor Thor
in turn calls back out to to the to the
dwarves again and says give me more
hammers and they just bring like
thousands of hammers crashing down on
the earth so it's literally Thor
fighting juggernaut with thousands of
hammers and we don't initially see it
all happen in fact we don't we only see
him pick up like one of the hammers and
then use that hammer to like crush to
talk about across the face and then you
just skip to the next scene which is
kind of pointing because I would kind of
want to see Thor fight juggernaut with
thousand hammers because like when he
gets there when he takes the the I and
he gets back to the divorce he ends up
telling him yeah I had to use them all
like I had to use all the hammers and so
they've all been destroyed
I need more which is kind of funny but
it's a little bit sad cuz again like I
would kind of wanted to see that I know
you guys do nobody ever watches Thor to
see him talk people people like they
read Thor comics like they want to see
Thor's like smash and stuff is it the
Incredible Hulk people just like yeah I
want to see The Incredible Hulk smash
things
I know how you guys are cuz I'm the same
way I'm the exact same way but uh but
the fact remains that we end up having
him basically travel to visit directly
without with Odin and when he's talking
to Odin Odin actually asked about her
and of course this is own referring to
Jane Foster and this has been a change
for his character and his name is
interesting because Jane Foster had
earned the respect of Odin at the end of
the story arc because when all the
Asgardians failed and in the moment of
testing when Odin was basically faced
with man god the one being in the entire
Marvel Universe that Odin is actually
scared of Jane Foster was the only one
to stand up and rise to the challenge
and so she basically she picked up the
slack where Odin was weak and that
really earned some some brownie points
and or some respect from Odin so that's
when he asked the question do you know
where she is because Odin is actually
concerned about Jane Foster which is a
total change because Odin was a
reflection of a portion of the fan base
who were just like no Jane Foster does
not need to be Thor QT was written to
kind of be that way or at least that
seems to have been the case and so now
he's just kind of like yeah like like
what happened to her but then you end up
having Thor transition back to Midgard
and in the Bronx no less and meet up
with meet up with Jane Foster only for
us to find out that again the war of
realms is still going on so Malekith the
accursed this warlord of the Dark Elves
is still like running across all the
various realms and destroying everything
that he can find and literally just like
like just laying siege to everything
they just just annihilating everything
that he can find that's really all he's
doing and so we end up finding out that
that like a lot of these refugees these
various elves and dwarves and so on and
so forth who have fled from their realms
are being given safe passage in in the
Bronx and not only that Jane Foster is
actually recovering from her cancer so
it's really basically Jason Erin's way
of saying she's not gone yet which I'm
very excited about that makes me very
very happy I'm very pleased to see that
but it's really kind of the aftermath of
Adz guards destruction you have like
like for example Heimdall lost his eyes
so we can't see everything mean he could
not see into the into the other realms
and see how the realms are faring the
Bifrost bridge is broken so Thor can't
go there as guards basically cut off
from everywhere except for Midgard
that's really the only place he can get
to and so we really have Jane Foster
essentially tell for that the next
weapon he's looking for is something
called the gem of infinite Suns and for
the most part it's exactly what it
sounds like it's a gem that houses the
power of a thousand stars the reason why
it matters is if you go back and you
read the old stories the old Thor
stories there was a point where he was
attacked with the casket of ancient
winters which creates like infinite cold
and the gym of infinite Suns countered
that it's basically the yin and the yang
to the to the casket of ancient winters
a kind of exists you know as yin and
yang to each other but tracking that
down again it's just another weapon that
was lost from from Asgard which Thor is
trying to locate now for the most part
it initially seems like busywork right
it just kind of seems like well Thor's
just kind of here doing things and
tracking down weapons and so on and so
forth and it doesn't really seem like he
serves a purpose but this changes when
Loki shows up here we basically find out
that Thor has been taking all these
weapons in like throwing him to a
singular location and well really on a
boat and which is kind of cool to see a
Thor like partying on a yacht but still
Loki showing up here are likely a Jason
Aaron does this because Thor is
immediately hostile to him right because
he's like hey look you stabbed free in
the back of the beginning of this whole
thing the start of the war of realms and
it was a poisoned dagger and freya was
unconscious and almost dead for quite
some time
but again the way that Jason Aaron has
done this he's been riding Loki in such
a way to where it seems like there's
actually something else going on and
Jason here has been tight-lipped about
it like we have no idea it's just
there's something else happening here
aside from Loki just turning against
Freya and joining Malekith in the war of
realms we don't know exactly what it is
but it seems like he's not entirely evil
anymore
and so when he Williams are basically
telling Thor he essentially tells him
look you're gonna have to go on a
journey here and this journey you're
gonna go on is going to locate one of
the weapons you're looking for but it's
the weapon that will win the war and so
it's kind of cool because that entices
Thor to a degree enough for him to kind
of stop in and ask the question what are
we talking about and Loki says well you
have to go on a journey and find out and
opens a portal and since the war off to
another location so the funny thing
about this is Thor is just like nope I'm
not going alone and grabs Loki and drags
him and Loki is just like what are you
doing man like you're gonna mess up the
spell so it's kind of a funny moment
between two brothers and we end up
finding out that where Loki has taken
Thor to is the realm of nifflheim now I
want to have a little bit of a
discussion here and I want to talk about
how the war of realms is kind of what it
really means here so all in all the war
of realms has only really been confined
to a couple different place or at least
shown to us in a couple different places
it has been mentioned of course
seem sort of often on Worst expanded
across the realms but all in all it's
been dealing largely with like Jane
Foster how she's coping with it so on
and so forth because she was the star of
the Thor stories for some time but the
war of realms again is kind of led by
Malekith and so what's going on here in
nifflheim is that nifflheim actually
houses a subset of the realm that's
called Helheim which is essentially just
the afterlife now we've talked about
this before in previous videos so for
those of you guys who have heard this
bear with me but the realm of Hell in in
Marvel Comics is not a place of like
punishment right like it's not a place
of of torment when it comes to those who
follow the Norse mythological ideology
but do not die an honorable battle they
go to Helheim those individuals who do
die an honorable battle they go to
Valhalla now that's just confined to
those individuals on earth and mobile
comics who believe in like the the
North's mythological deities and so on
and so forth other religions travel to
other after worlds and so again it's
really kind of spread out across the
entire landscape of what could be the
afterlife based on different realms and
so on and so forth but what's been going
on here is the realm of Hell is
currently being ruled over by a guy
named Balder now Balder of course is the
brother of Thor and he's long since been
dead and in true Norse mythology here in
the real world the death of Balder
signals the beginning of Ragnarok in
Marvel Comics the death of Boulder's
just the death of Balder it doesn't
really mean anything it was just kind of
jack her be back in the day following
Norse mythology but making it taking a
few liberties to kind of make it fit
within the confines of Marvel Comics but
at the moment right now there's a few
things going on here now for those of
you guys who have read my or who have
seen my video on Thanos or who have read
the actual Thanos comic by Jeff Lemire
you essentially kind of know what's
going on up but what it essentially
happened kind of winding the clock back
a little bit Marvel introduced a
character named Angela now Angela was a
kid she was really from like the spawn
mythos the issue was that the creator of
Angela from the spawn comics left image
comics and came to Marvel and when he
did because image is basically a creator
owned company whereby each creation
that's made by a writer goes with them
they own it in its entirety
Angela ended up coming along with that
particular that particular cradle I
can't member his name off top my head
but she ended up coming with that
creator Marvel wrote her an and then
didn't really know what to do with her
and so what they did is they wrote a
story called Angela Queen of Hell where
she basically invaded the realm of Hell
invaded Niflheim and then defeated hella
cast her out of her own realm and then
took it over and eventually Balder took
the place of Angela and then that's
where things sort of stand right now so
at the moment he'll is just kind of
free-floating
she's just out there now originally she
made a bargain with Thanos for the
purpose of using his power to risa cure
her rule over hell and we're just kind
of in limbo waiting for that to happen
which will actually happen in this story
but at the moment that's why Thor's
brother is the one ruling over hell now
the other half of this is a character by
the name of sender now sinner of course
it previously appeared we talked about
her before but for those again who were
kind of catching up here the idea behind
sender is that she's essentially the
daughter of Surtur now Serdar had a lot
of offspring but the difference between
sender and all the other offspring that
he had was that when they were given a
choice sender chose the flame she chose
to follow her father's path and so the
result was that Surtur kept his daughter
alive and then what Sirte was killed by
odin cinder a CIMMYT as ruler of muscled
hunk and so she's the one who just kind
of rules everything and so Balder is
technically the ruler of hell but not
really because he just doesn't have the
power necessary in order to defeat
sender and so things is sort of in
pandemonium right now senators got her
forces all over all over the realm of
nifflheim try to find those who are
usurpers who would try to take out her
power and so of course Loki and Thor
being here presents a credible threat
and that's the reason why right off the
bat the forces of cinders start to
arrive and they have to basically
face-off against them and cast them out
as best they can now again because of
the fact that a lot of these different
warriors here are in Hell what this
means is that they've effectively died
nifflheim is basically a round that's
really home more to like the deceased or
those who represent the deceased these
are individuals whose mythological
stories sort of goes hand in hand with
what it means to be dead even if they
aren't technically dead I mean for the
most part they all are but again Surtur
is effectively making a meal kind of
making a pact with all of them basically
saying look I'm ruling this place and
while she's not really saying it in so
many words she's basically admitting
that she's ruling by the skin of her
teeth and what she needs are the forces
of all these other guys to go alongside
her to one make sure they won't try to
challenge her rule which is to say
banned against her in overthrow who
forces which they could and at the other
at the same time because cinder herself
is essentially working alongside
Malekith who's leading the war of realms
the alliance between cinder and these
forces in Niflheim would expand the
forces of Malekith even further so again
it's a massive campaign and that's kind
of what's being talked about here and
these discussions with with Balder these
discussions with Thor with tear who
actually joins the ranks again another
another friend of Thor who's been dead
for quite some time now this is kind of
a cool scenario because when this whole
thing happens what you end up basically
getting is is the return of Helen with
Fenris and I guess Fenrir I think is how
you pronounce it Finn Rhee I'm not a
hundred percent sure how to pronounce
that name but again basically showing
back up here and
look like I'm here to reclaim my realm
so again it's kind of cool to see all
this pop off but everything's sort of
shuffling and and being moved around and
being bounced around now again it's kind
of interesting because for hella herself
her ability to reclaim the realm not
necessarily guaranteed in the sense that
hell is powerful especially inside her
own realm but just because she returns
to the queen of health doesn't mean that
everybody would honor that that return
everybody would say okay we recognize
you as a legitimate queen and so what
this means is that for hella she
basically forms a marriage with Balder
in order to effectively secure the
allegiance of those who were loyal to
Balder as well as maintain those
followers who were loyal to her and so
because the fact of this alliance is of
is basically being formed here the
forces of hella and Balder and Thor face
off against the forces of cinder and for
the most part they hold their own but
what they need here is an additional
source of power what they need here are
those individuals who are capable of
fighting because within the realm of
hell these are like murderers and
thieves and different things like that
and even if they were gonna fight
alongside Thor which they're not they're
not really warriors because of their
warriors they would be in Valhalla and
so because of this the issue that Thor
faces is you cannot simply go to
Valhalla right like it's the one place
you can access when only created
Valhalla and establish it as a place for
the for those who died an honorable
battle the perspective of Odin was they
did their time they fought their fight
they don't need to fight anymore
and so they basically need to spend the
afterlife in peace enjoying their
stories telling their tales getting
drunk
that's as though it's basically a
peaceful afterlife cutting it off from
really the entirety of the universe
where no one can access it is the only
way to guarantee that now again we are
talking about the power of Odin which is
not absolute there are those out there
who are more powerful than he is and
that's one of the cool things about Loki
is that what Loki does is basically tell
for I can get you there like I can get
you into Valhalla because one of the
things to bear in mind when it comes to
Loki's character is that as powerful as
he is and as capable as he is at the end
of the day he's not on the same level as
Odin but he does know a lot of these
back channels for lack of a better word
and using his magic to access places
he's not really supposed to get to so in
effect he can use his magic to create a
kind of pocket back door which will give
for access to Valhalla proper the issue
is that when he gets there because Odin
and the Valkyrie and those who go to
Valhalla are the only ones who are
supposed to know where its existence is
when Thor arrives you immediately have
Brunhilde leader of the Valkyrie who's
like you're not supposed to be here but
you're not dead and because you're not
dead you cannot access Valhalla and so
she's basically the gatekeeper the one
who decides who can enter and who cannot
now at the same time this is happening
at the same time all this is going down
Balder and even the forces of cinder are
kind of like look we're not really
siding with hella proper and so because
he'll are really kind of turned to
position and tries to kind of brute
force her way in what is up happening is
they're met with the arrival of Thanos
and this is kind of a funny thing
because what this is is basically Jason
Aaron's way of kind of removing Thanos
from the equation and throwing him into
infinity wars because infinity wars was
going on at the time this story was
being written and so the result is that
where infinity wars was not really good
I would argue this was probably an
editorial mandate that in reality Thanos
fighting against the forces of of
nifflheim fighting in Hell alongside
hella
would actually be a sight to behold and
so because of the fact that she had
previously struck a pact with him what
this does is at least to Thanos turning
against hella and effectively walking
away and the reason why was because
again Jason Aaron presumably by
editorial mandate I don't really know
what goes on behind the scenes had to
remove Thanos from the equation so that
US could essentially be a part of like
the infinity wars conflict so again kind
of lame here with a nose basically
leaves and basically walks away and says
hey looked like my mistress calls and
the Infinity stones demand my attention
so does kind of like mistress death is
back I'm going to see her I'll see you
when I see you peace now within the
context of the story it works because
Thanos has always prized mistress death
above everybody else and even in the
famous line of stories he basically told
hella you're no mistress death but
you'll do for right now that's kind of
the the stance that he took and so it
made sense for what it was but Thanos
actually leaving and joining the realm
of the of Hell and like facing off
against all those forces would have been
really really really cool to see and so
again with Thor basically speaking
directly to Brunhilde and essentially
saying look like we need your forces
because the realms are collapsing we
need all the honorable dead that are
here in Valhalla ultimately Brunhilde
ends up agreeing here now this is very
big and the reason why is because this
is everyone who's ever fought
who's ever died an honorable battle in
the name of the Asgardian mythos
everyone who's ever died an honorable
battle presumably on earth possibly
other places who have believed in the
Asgardian mythos are here and so they're
basically gonna be joining with Thor and
showing up to fight against the forces
of hella and it's actually really really
really cool to see and it's pretty
awesome to watch it all unfold because
when this happens the forces of cinder
are squashed and almost like the blink
of an eye they are readily crushed now
one thing to bear in mind here is that
just because they're in the
realm of Health does not mean they
cannot die again now that's the question
that's not answered here what happens
when they do
originally before mistress death was
introduced there was only the realm of
hell and so the answer to Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby gave doctor in the 60s and
70s was that when you die if you die an
honorable battle you go to Valhalla if
you don't you go to the realm of hell
and that's it
when mistress death was introduced then
we actually got an afterlife for those
who don't believe in the Asgardian
mythos the question is not being
answered here is if you die either in
the realm of Hell or in Valhalla do you
go to the realm of mistress death is
that the one tried and true afterlife
that's not really the answer that we're
given here and so again with Thor
basically taking the power of Hell alike
Thor becoming the ruler of Hell
basically usually like this flaming
battle ax which looks absolutely amazing
and then crushing the entirety of the
forces of cinder what this means is she
basically retreats and responds to this
ball door acquiesce as Helen returns
back to being ruler of hell and for the
most part things kind of seem to be set
the way they're supposed to be and so
what this means is that with the realm
the war of realms effectively starting
that hella is now back to being ruler of
hell these are as they were before and
it's just a matter of really asking the
question will the forces of nifflheim
will they join the forces of fork
alongside all the superheroes and
presumably supervillains who exist in
the Marvel Universe as well as the
Warriors of Valhalla to face off against
the forces of Malekith that's really the
question that's being asked here and
it's the question we do not have a
definitive answer to but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain miss you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]